- Um, it's back!
- Star Wars is back!
- Yeah, baby, yeah!
- Do you know how long
I've been waiting for this?
I was practically raised on this film.
- I know, it's like
welcoming back old friends.
- And welcoming new ones to the family.
- The brunette.
Dude, that chick, she's so hot.
- Hella fine.
- And the trailer?
- I cried.
- [Man in Plaid] You did?
- That's how epic it was.
And those effects?
- Incredible.
I mean, how long has it been since
we've had a Star Wars film?
- It's been at least a decade.
- Wow, that was a long time ago.
- [Both] In a galaxy far, far away!
("Star Wars Main Theme")
♫ Bohm, bohm
♫ Bohm, bohm, bohm ♫
Sorry.
Oh, god, we gotta roll if
we want front row seats.
Okay, this film is gonna be the bomb.
- There's no way they can screw this up.
- [Man in Plaid] No, are you kidding me?
(dramatic music)
(heavy sobs)
What did I just watch?
(screaming sobs)
(dramatic music)